[Applause]
oh right now as you can see at 6.31
cents a gallon or i remember it being
250 or even three dollars i used to put
38 dollars to fill my tank up now it's
about that's what you saw between 70 and
90
i think that's crazy
you know work i basically have to use my
card to go to work but yeah i do my
vehicle a little bit less because of the
gas
yeah look at that full tank
72-91
you know there's people that have to
support families and go to work
and they have to depend on a car so
i don't see why
this is not this should be a priority
for people to have affordable gas
a hybrid yes
so
in the city this is great gas mileage
the hybrid
i think it's disgusting what's going on
but i don't see why
gas prices should go up because of
our involvement in the ukraine
i mean
yeah if they want to support them fine
but why do we have to have higher gas
prices if that's the case
uh it's about 24 miles per gallon so
not great but it's affordable
great corporate grade
i think it's the entire system's
regulated on how many barrels
everybody's releasing and they always
like to play a supply and demand game
the supplies there they just choose
whether or not they're going to release
it so they can
you know fix our oil by barrel prices
and continually charging us more at the
gas stations because they want to keep
their profitability up to keep their
shareholders happy
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]